- Witaj ponownie w kursie Rozumienie Informacji
i Obliczeń Kwantowych.
Mam na imię John Watrous i jestem dyrektorem technicznym
ds. Edukacji w IBM Quantum.
To druga lekcja z serii. Jeśli jeszcze nie obejrzałeś
pierwszej lekcji, koniecznie to zrób.
Będziemy bezpośrednio rozwijać tematy omówione
w pierwszej lekcji, więc ważne jest, żebyś
rozumiał tamten materiał przed przystąpieniem do tej lekcji.
Pamiętaj też, że seria
zawiera treści z podręcznika oprócz filmów, a link
do treści podręcznikowych
znajdziesz w opisie filmu. To jest lekcja druga
z jednostki pierwszej serii.
Jednostka pierwsza obejmuje podstawy
informacji kwantowej.
W poprzedniej lekcji omawialiśmy informację kwantową w kontekście pojedynczych układów, co oznacza, że mamy jeden
układ przechowujący informację
i opisujemy, jak
działa w izolacji.
Poświęciliśmy sporo czasu
na informację klasyczną, głównie po to, żeby ustalić punkt odniesienia i podkreślić matematyczne podobieństwa
między informacją kwantową a klasyczną.
Zobaczyliśmy też, jak stany kwantowe można reprezentować przez wektory, konkretnie wektory o
współczynnikach zespolonych i euklidesowej normie równej jeden,
oraz omówiliśmy pomiary
w bazie standardowej i operacje unitarne.
W tej lekcji rozszerzymy nasz
punkt widzenia na wiele układów, z których każdy jest zdolny do
przechowywania informacji kwantowej.
To nie jest prosta kwestia stwierdzenia, że każdy pojedynczy układ
działa tak, jak omawialiśmy ostatnio; jest pewien sens, w którym całość
jest większa niż suma części — i to samo dotyczy
informacji klasycznej, gdy w grę wchodzą prawdopodobieństwa.
Wiele układów może
oddziaływać ze sobą i mogą być ze sobą skorelowane
na przykład, a w ujęciu kwantowym obejmuje to możliwość,
że układy są splątane, co jest pojęciem, które
być może już gdzieś słyszałeś.
Splątanie jest bardzo
ważnym zjawiskiem w informacji kwantowej i będziemy mieć o nim jeszcze wiele do powiedzenia w miarę kontynuowania serii.
Jest jednak pewna prosta zasada, która daje nam całkiem sporo możliwości myślenia o
i rozumienia informacji kwantowej dla wielu układów,
a mianowicie, że zawsze możemy
wziąć dwa lub więcej układów i złączyć je razem lub po prostu koncepcyjnie
myśleć o nich razem
i traktować je tak, jakby tworzyły
jeden złożony układ.
A gdy myślimy o
złożonym układzie w ten sposób, jak o pojedynczym układzie, uznajemy, że musi być opisany w sposób spójny
z wszystkim, czego się nauczyliśmy
w poprzedniej lekcji o pojedynczych układach.
Zobaczymy, jak to działa
i jak opis informacji kwantowej
dla wielu układów wyłania się dość naturalnie z tego, jak działa dla pojedynczych układów,
opierając się na tej jednej zasadzie. Oto przegląd lekcji i jest on identyczny jak przegląd poprzedniej lekcji,
ale tym razem skupimy się
na wielu układach, a nie na pojedynczych.
Tak jak w poprzedniej lekcji i dokładnie z tych samych powodów, zaczniemy od
informacji klasycznej.
Ponownie zobaczymy
bardzo bliskie podobieństwa między sposobem, w jaki działa informacja kwantowa
i klasyczna na poziomie matematycznym.
Zazwyczaj nie będziemy tak bardzo skupiać się
na informacji klasycznej ani zaczynać każdej lekcji serii od informacji klasycznej w ten sposób.
Kolejne lekcje będą raczej skupiać się znacznie wyłączniej na informacji i obliczeniach kwantowych.
Ale tutaj, na początku,
to sensowne podejście i nawiązuje do idei, że myślenie o informacji klasycznej
może służyć jako cenne źródło wskazówek do zrozumienia informacji kwantowej.
Omówimy też
ważne pojęcie iloczynu tensorowego
w tej części lekcji.
Iloczyny tensorowe są niezwykle ważne w informacji kwantowej, ale pojawiają się też w
ujęciu klasycznym.
Następnie przejdziemy do informacji kwantowej i podobnie jak w poprzedniej lekcji omówimy stany kwantowe,
pomiary w bazie standardowej,
i operacje unitarne, tym razem
dla wielu układów.
Zaczniemy od omówienia
stanów klasycznych wielu układów.
Przypomnij sobie z poprzedniej
lekcji, że stan klasyczny układu to
konfiguracja tego układu, którą można rozpoznać i
opisać jednoznacznie
bez żadnej niepewności ani błędu. A w terminach matematycznych, gdy mówimy o zbiorze stanów klasycznych,
mamy po prostu na myśli zbiór skończony i niepusty.
Rozpoczniemy nasze omówienie
wielu układów, zakładając, że mamy
tylko dwa układy X i Y.
X ma pewien zbiór stanów klasycznych, który nazwiemy sigma, tak
samo jak w poprzedniej lekcji, a Y ma pewien zbiór stanów klasycznych,
który nazwiemy gamma. Zbiory sigma i gamma
mogą być tym samym zbiorem lub mogą być różne,
ale nadajemy im różne nazwy nie tylko dlatego, że
mogą być różnymi zbiorami, ale też dlatego, że pomoże
nam zachować przejrzystość, jeśli nadamy im różne nazwy.
Okaże się, że całkiem
łatwo jest uogólnić całe to omówienie z dwóch układów na dowolną liczbę układów, ale
zaczynając od dwóch układów,
możemy skupić się na podstawowych ideach bez zagłębiania się w szczegóły.
WEBVTT
Wyobraź sobie teraz, że
stawiamy X i Y obok siebie z X po lewej i Y po prawej, i patrzymy na te dwa układy razem
tak, jakby tworzyły jeden złożony układ.
Żeby nadać temu nowemu układowi nazwę, możemy zapisać go jako
parę uporządkowaną w ten sposób, albo możemy po prostu zestawić
obie litery razem w ten sposób.
Obie formy są powszechne i możemy
wybrać tę, którą chcemy, lub tę, która jest wygodniejsza.
Tak czy inaczej, będziemy to odczytywać jako XY.
Bardzo naturalne pytanie,
które można w tym miejscu zadać, to jakie są stany klasyczne tego nowego złożonego układu XY?
A odpowiedź na to pytanie jest taka, że zbiór stanów klasycznych XY to iloczyn kartezjański
tych dwóch zbiorów stanów klasycznych,
sigma i gamma, który
możesz zobaczyć zdefiniowany tutaj.
W danym momencie X ma pewien stan klasyczny,
który jest elementem sigma, a Y ma pewien stan klasyczny,
który jest elementem gamma,
i po prostu traktujemy
te dwa stany razem, jak gdyby tworzyły jeden stan, i to jest dokładnie pojęcie,
które uchwytuje iloczyn kartezjański. Mamy dwa elementy,
po jednym z każdego zbioru, i chcemy myśleć
o tych dwóch elementach razem
tak, jakby tworzyły jeden
element z jednego zbioru.
Żeby być precyzyjnym, jest tu pewne założenie, a mianowicie, że wiemy,
który z naszych układów to X, a który to Y,
i nie ma między nimi żadnej pomyłki. Nie jest ważne, żeby X fizycznie znajdował się po lewej
stronie, a Y po prawej,
ale raczej żeby te dwa
układy były odróżnialne i żebyśmy zdecydowali
się je uszeregować w ten sposób tylko po to, żebyśmy mogli
wiedzieć, który jest który.
Oto bardzo prosty przykład, gdzie sigma to alfabet binarny, a gamma to zbiór
zawierający cztery kolory kart.
Jeśli X przechowuje wartość binarną, a Y przechowuje jeden z czterech kolorów kart, to jest osiem
możliwych stanów klasycznych
pary XY, które
możesz zobaczyć wymienione tutaj.
Dla więcej niż dwóch układów generalizuje się to w prosty sposób.
W szczególności, jeśli X1 przez Xn to układy mające zbiory stanów klasycznych sigma jeden przez sigma n odpowiednio.
To jeśli wyobrazimy sobie grupowanie
tych n układów razem i traktowanie ich jako jednego układu, zbiorem stanów klasycznych jest
iloczyn kartezjański
n zbiorów stanów klasycznych
sigma jeden przez sigma n.
Jak widać tutaj na ekranie. Iloczyn kartezjański
można zdefiniować w ten sposób dla dowolnej liczby zbiorów.
Na przykład, jeśli mamy trzy układy i wszystkie mają alfabet binarny jako swój zbiór stanów klasycznych, czyli innymi słowy mamy trzy bity,
to jest osiem
możliwych stanów klasycznych trzech bitów traktowanych
razem jako jeden układ i możesz je zobaczyć wymienione tutaj.
Każdy układ indywidualnie może
być w stanie zero lub jeden, i przechodzimy przez wszystkie
możliwe kombinacje.
n-krotka stanów klasycznych może być alternatywnie zapisana jako ciąg znaków, gdzie pomijamy
nawiasy i przecinki, jak widać tutaj.
I to jest szczególnie sensowne, gdy myślimy o
stanach klasycznych jako symbolach, jak w bardzo powszechnym przykładzie
alfabetu binarnego,
do którego wracamy. Czasami jest to bardzo wygodne i sprawia, że
nasze wyrażenia są prostsze
i mniej zaśmiecone. Pojęcie ciągu znaków jest właściwie sformalizowane
w terminach matematycznych przez iloczyny kartezjańskie,
więc to jest naprawdę tylko
alternatywna notacja, a nie coś konceptualnie innego.
Jako przykład, powiedzmy, że mamy
10 bitów X1 przez X10.
To oznacza, że zbiorem stanów klasycznych tych 10 bitów razem,
który możesz naturalnie traktować jako 10-bitowy rejestr
w komputerze na przykład,
jest dziesięciokrotny iloczyn kartezjański
alfabetu binarnego z sobą samym.
A jeśli zapisujemy te stany jak ciągi znaków, wyglądają jak widać tutaj, jest ich 1024,
więc oczywiście nie wszystkie są tu wymienione. Te trzy kropki tutaj
mają wskazywać, że istnieje wzorzec, który możesz wydedukować,
i mam nadzieję, że rozumiesz ideę. Teraz jest pewna konwencja,
którą będziemy stosować przy porządkowaniu elementów
zbiorów iloczynu kartezjańskiego,
i ważne jest
wyjaśnienie tego dla potrzeb reprezentowania zarówno stanów probabilistycznych, jak i stanów kwantowych jako wektorów.
Konwencja jest taka, że
porządkujemy elementy zbiorów iloczynu kartezjańskiego
leksykograficznie, co w zasadzie oznacza
porządek słownikowy.
Mówiąc dokładniej, zaczynamy od założenia, że każdy z indywidualnych zbiorów, z których bierzemy iloczyn kartezjański, ma już swoje własne uporządkowanie,
i traktujemy daną n-krotkę lub ciąg znaków jak słowo i
porządkujemy je alfabetycznie.
Innym sposobem na powiedzenie tego jest stwierdzenie, że pozycje w
n-krotce lub ciągu znaków maleją co do ważności
od lewej do prawej,
tak jak gdy zapisujemy liczby przy użyciu cyfr od zera do dziewięciu.
Oto przykład, który ma
wyjaśnić to zagadnienie.
Jeśli weźmiemy iloczyn kartezjański zbiorów zawierających
jeden, dwa i trzy oraz alfabetu binarnego, otrzymamy zbiór zawierający sześć elementów
i tutaj są one wymienione w
opisywanym porządku.
Wszystkie elementy z
jedynką na pierwszej pozycji pojawiają się przed wszystkimi elementami z dwójką na pierwszej pozycji i pojawiają się przed wszystkimi elementami
WEBVTT
z trójką na pierwszej pozycji. A gdy dwa elementy
zgadzają się na pierwszej pozycji, opieramy się na porządku
na drugiej pozycji.
Taki jest więc porządek, który
stosujemy dla iloczynów kartezjańskich.
Zauważ, że gdy stosujemy tę konwencję i zapisujemy n-krotki jako ciągi znaków, obserwujemy pewne bardzo znane wzorce.
Na przykład, iloczyn kartezjański alfabetu
binarnego z sobą samym jest uporządkowany jak widać tutaj,
i możesz myśleć o tych ciągach znaków jako o ciągach uporządkowanych numerycznie, jeśli traktujesz te ciągi
jako binarne kodowania nieujemnych liczb całkowitych, i to się uogólnia
na dowolną długość ciągu. Przechodząc do stanów probabilistycznych, wiemy już z poprzedniej lekcji,
że stan probabilistyczny przypisuje prawdopodobieństwo każdemu stanowi klasycznemu
danego układu.
Jeśli mamy złożony układ, gdzie wzięliśmy dwa lub więcej układów i traktujemy je łącznie jak gdyby tworzyły jeden
układ, jak właśnie omawialiśmy,
to stan probabilistyczny
tego złożonego układu musi przypisywać prawdopodobieństwa elementom iloczynu kartezjańskiego
poszczególnych układów,
zbiorów stanów klasycznych. Tak jest dlatego, że to właśnie jest
zbiorem stanów klasycznych złożonego układu.
Na przykład, zakładając,
że X i Y to bity, mamy ten przykład
stanu probabilistycznego XY.
Prawdopodobieństwo, że oba
bity mają wartość zero, wynosi jedna druga, a prawdopodobieństwo, że oba
bity mają wartość jeden, wynosi jedna druga, więc dwa bity nigdy się nie różnią.
To jest prawidłowy stan probabilistyczny XY, i możemy go alternatywnie
zapisać jako wektor
jak widać tutaj, i tutaj możesz zobaczyć, że
stosujemy konwencję, którą opisałem chwilę temu dotyczącą porządkowania tych stanów klasycznych.
To jest przykład
stanu probabilistycznego, gdzie X i Y są skorelowane, i to jest sens, w którym całość
jest większa niż suma części. Jak sugerowałem wcześniej, nie jest tak po prostu, że
mamy stan probabilistyczny
X i stan probabilistyczny Y i łączymy je razem, ale raczej najpierw łączymy
układy razem
a potem myślimy o
stanach probabilistycznych złożonego układu.
Żeby być bardziej precyzyjnym co do
korelacji między układami, zaczynamy od zdefiniowania
pojęcia niezależności, co jest zasadniczo
brakiem korelacji.
Tutaj nawiasem mówiąc, termin niezależność odnosi się
do niezależności statystycznej, w odróżnieniu od liniowej niezależności
wektorów na przykład.
To podstawowe pojęcie
w rachunku prawdopodobieństwa i statystyce.
Jeśli mamy dwa układy X i Y i mamy jakiś stan probabilistyczny
XY, to mówimy, że X i Y są niezależne,
jeśli formuła, którą
widzisz tutaj, jest prawdziwa dla każdego wyboru stanów klasycznych
a i b układów X i Y.
Jednym ze sposobów interpretacji tego
warunku niezależności jest to, że mówi on, iż prawdopodobieństwo, że X będzie w jakimkolwiek jednym stanie klasycznym,
i prawdopodobieństwo, że Y będzie w jakimś innym stanie klasycznym, nie mają absolutnie nic
ze sobą wspólnego.
Tak więc dowiedzenie się, w jakim stanie
jest jeden z układów, nie wpływa na
prawdopodobieństwa związane ze stanami drugiego układu.
Jeśli wyobrazimy sobie losowe wybieranie
jakiegoś stanu klasycznego X według pewnej procedury, a następnie losowe wybieranie
jakiegoś stanu klasycznego Y
według jakiejś innej procedury, która nie jest w żaden sposób
powiązana z tą dla X, jak na przykład gdy jedna osoba rzuca monetą
a inna osoba w
innym pokoju rzuca kostką, to jest wzór,
który byś użył do uzyskania prawdopodobieństw
dla różnych kombinacji
stanów. Sens definicji jest taki, że niezależność jest
wtedy, gdy formuła jest spełniona.
Kiedy myślimy o stanach probabilistycznych w kategoriach wektorów prawdopodobieństwa, istnieje proste sformułowanie
tego warunku,
a mianowicie, jeśli mamy
stan probabilistyczny XY, który możemy wyrazić jako
wektor w notacji ket,
jak widać tutaj. Wtedy powiedzenie, że X i Y są niezależne, jest równoważne istnieniu
dwóch wektorów prawdopodobieństwa,
ket Phi i ket Psi, które nawiasem mówiąc możemy
po prostu odczytywać jako Phi i Psi dla zwięzłości, reprezentujących
stany probabilistyczne X i Y osobno, które spełniają tę równość,
którą widzisz tutaj.
Dla wszystkich wyborów a i b, to jest zasadniczo
przeformułowanie definicji w kategoriach wektorów.
Na przykład, oto stan probabilistyczny
pary bitów XY, dla której X i Y są niezależne.
Warunek wymagany
do niezależności jest spełniony dla wektorów,
które widzisz tutaj.
To znaczy, prawdopodobieństwo
dla każdego możliwego ustawienia dwóch bitów jest dane przez iloczyn odpowiadających prawdopodobieństw
dla poszczególnych bitów.
Na przykład, prawdopodobieństwo, że oba
bity przyjmują wartość zero, jest równe jednej szóstej, co jest równe jednej
czwartej razy dwie trzecie,
i podobnie dla
pozostałych trzech możliwości, które można sprawdzić po kolei.
Dla stanu probabilistycznego, który widzieliśmy wcześniej, z drugiej strony, gdzie mamy dwa bity, które zawsze się zgadzają i przyjmują wartości zero i
jeden z prawdopodobieństwem jedna druga,
nie mamy niezależności i dlatego mówimy, że
bity są skorelowane.
Korelacja oznacza po prostu
brak niezależności.
Prostym sposobem na wykazanie, że
dwa bity nie są niezależne, jest założenie, że są, i wyprowadzenie sprzeczności.
A mianowicie, jeśli dwa
bity byłyby niezależne, musiałyby istnieć
liczby q0, q1, r0 i r1,
WEBVTT
reprezentujące prawdopodobieństwa
dla dwóch pojedynczych bitów tak, żeby te równania
tutaj były spełnione.
To są prawdopodobieństwa
pochodzące z naszego wektora, a to są
równania, które muszą być spełnione zgodnie z warunkiem niezależności.
Ale jeśli przyjrzymy się tej
drugiej równości tutaj, widzimy, że wymaga ona, żeby
q0 razy r1 było równe zero,
ale jedynym sposobem, w jaki
iloczyn dwóch liczb rzeczywistych może być równy zero, jest to, że przynajmniej jedna z tych
liczb sama jest równa zero.
Nazywa się to czasem
własnością zerowego iloczynu liczb rzeczywistych.
Innym sposobem na powiedzenie tego jest stwierdzenie, że iloczyn dwóch niezerowych liczb rzeczywistych
jest zawsze niezerowy.
Tak więc ta równość tutaj
implikuje, że albo q0 jest równe zero, albo r1 jest równe zero,
ale z pierwszej i ostatniej równości widzimy, że żadna z
tych dwóch alternatyw nie może być prawdziwa.
Jeśli q0 jest równe zero, to ten iloczyn musiałby być równy zero, ale nie jest równy zero,
a jeśli r1 jest równe zero,
to ten iloczyn musiałby być równy zero, ale to też nie jest prawdą.
Mamy więc sprzeczność
i wnioskujemy, że X i Y nie są niezależne, więc są skorelowane.
Pojęcie niezależności,
które właśnie omówiliśmy, a w szczególności jego sformułowanie w kategoriach wektorów
prawdopodobieństwa, jest ściśle powiązane
z operacją, którą można
wykonywać na wektorach, zwaną iloczynem tensorowym.
Iloczyny tensorowe można
definiować nie tylko dla wektorów, ale też dla macierzy,
a w rzeczywistości pojęcie iloczynu tensorowego można zdefiniować
dla wielu innych rodzajów
obiektów matematycznych.
Można je opisywać
w dość abstrakcyjny sposób, który jest zarówno ważny, jak i
użyteczny w matematyce czystej, ale możemy też definiować
iloczyny tensorowe dla wektorów
w bardzo prosty i konkretny sposób, i to jest ścieżka, którą
obierzemy w tej lekcji.
Jeśli mamy dwa wektory kolumnowe Phi i Psi zapisane w postaciach, które widzisz tutaj, gdzie sigma i gamma to dowolne
wybrane zbiory stanów klasycznych
lub indeksy, jeśli wolisz, to iloczyn tensorowy tych wektorów to wektor, który widzisz tutaj.
Przechodzimy przez wszystkie elementy
iloczynu kartezjańskiego tych dwóch zbiorów, sigma i gamma, i wpis tego
wektora odpowiadający
każdej parze ab, która
jest tu zapisana jako ciąg znaków, jest równy iloczynowi
odpowiadających wpisów
tych dwóch wektorów. Innymi słowy, wpis ab iloczynu Phi tensor Psi jest iloczynem wpisu a
Phi i wpisu b Psi,
i to jest znaczenie
tego, co jest tu zapisane.
W istocie, jest to ta sama operacja, którą widzieliśmy chwilę temu, gdy omawialiśmy niezależność,
i teraz po prostu nadajemy jej nazwę.
Oto dokładnie ten sam przykład,
który widzieliśmy chwilę temu, zapisany bardziej explicite w
kategoriach iloczynu tensorowego.
Ponownie, jedna szósta jest równa jednej czwartej razy jedna trzecia, jedna dwunasta jest równa jednej czwartej
razy jedna trzecia i tak dalej.
Tutaj nawiasem mówiąc, są
kilka alternatywnych sposobów zapisu iloczynu
tensorowego dwóch wektorów.
Gdy używamy notacji ket i piszemy dwa kety
obok siebie w ten sposób, oznacza to iloczyn tensorowy.
Możesz więc myśleć o iloczynie tensorowym jako o domyślnym sposobie mnożenia dwóch wektorów kolumnowych razem.
Nie miałoby sensu
myśleć o iloczynie wektorów kolumnowych w ten sposób w kategoriach mnożenia macierzy, bo wymiary nie pasują,
więc naprawdę nie ma obawy
o niejednoznaczność tutaj.
Możemy też zapisywać
iloczyn tensorowy w ten sposób wewnątrz ketu i oznacza to
dokładnie to samo.
To jest iloczyn tensorowy
tych dwóch wektorów.
Pierwsza forma jest bardzo powszechna, a w rzeczywistości bardziej powszechne jest zapisywanie iloczynu tensorowego w ten sposób, bez symbolu iloczynu tensorowego,
niż ze symbolem. Druga forma jest
zdecydowanie znacznie mniej powszechna, ale czasami jest całkiem pomocna, głównie
jako sposób na wyeliminowanie potrzeby
dodatkowych nawiasów w pewnych sytuacjach.
Możemy też wyrażać
iloczyny tensorowe explicite w kategoriach rzeczywistych kolumn
liczb, jak widać tutaj,
jeśli weźmiemy iloczyn tensorowy tych dwóch wektorów kolumnowych tutaj, to jest wektor, który otrzymujemy,
i możesz zobaczyć, że wpisy tutaj są iloczynami wpisów
z tych dwóch wektorów.
Porządkowanie wpisów
iloczynu tensorowego jest spójne z
definicją sprzed chwili, pod warunkiem, że stosujemy konwencję
którą opisałem wcześniej dotyczącą porządkowania elementów
zbiorów iloczynu kartezjańskiego.
Stosowanie tej konwencji jest równoważne myśleniu
o indeksach pierwszego wektora jako
mających wyższe znaczenie niż indeksy drugiego wektora,
więc możesz zobaczyć, że
gdy przechodzimy przez wpisy iloczynu tensorowego, mamy wszystkie iloczyny zawierające pierwszy wpis
pierwszego wektora po lewej,
którym jest alfa jeden. Następnie wszystkie iloczyny
zawierające drugi wpis wektora po lewej,
którym jest alfa dwa i tak dalej.
Oto przykład, gdzie
wektor po lewej ma trzy wpisy, a wektor po
prawej ma cztery wpisy, żebyśmy mogli wyraźniej zobaczyć, co się dzieje.
WEBVTT
Mamy trzy wpisy w pierwszym wektorze, więc zaczynamy od zapisania trzech kopii drugiego wektora i mnożymy każdą z tych kopii
przez odpowiadający wpis
z pierwszego wektora w ten sposób.
Wnosimy alfy do środka w ten sposób, i tutaj po prostu
mnożymy wektory przez skalary.
A na koniec usuwamy
nawiasy z kopii i tworzymy jeden wektor kolumnowy,
jak widać tutaj.
Jako ważna uwaga, zauważ, że mamy następujące wzory na iloczyn tensorowy
wektorów bazy standardowej.
Jeśli weźmiemy iloczyn
tensorowy ketu a i ketu b, który możemy zapisać z
symbolem iloczynu tensorowego lub bez, jak widać tutaj,
to wynikiem jest po prostu ket ab.
Jeśli chcemy zapisać ab jako parę uporządkowaną zamiast ciągu znaków, możemy to zrobić i uzyskamy
to wyrażenie tutaj,
ale znacznie powszechniej
zapisuje się to tutaj, gdzie pomijamy nawiasy,
ale zostawiamy przecinek.
Jest pewien sens, w którym
ta z nawiasami jest może bardziej poprawna, ale jest to dość standardowa
konwencja w matematyce,
że nawiasy są pomijane, gdy nie są konieczne ani pomocne.
Możesz traktować je jako domyślne w tej formie tutaj i jest to po prostu mniej zaśmiecone
i ładniejsze w odbiorze.
Iloczyn tensorowy ma
ważną własność, a mianowicie jest dwuliniowy, co oznacza, że jest liniowy
w każdym z dwóch argumentów, pod warunkiem, że drugi jest ustalony.
Nieco dokładniej, jest
liniowy w pierwszym argumencie, co wyrażają te dwa równania, które widzisz tutaj.
Pierwsze mówi, że
jeśli dodamy dwa wektory, Phi1 i Phi2, a następnie weźmiemy
iloczyn tensorowy z Psi, otrzymamy taki sam wynik, jak gdybyśmy wzięli iloczyn tensorowy
z Psi najpierw, a potem dodali.
Drugie mówi, że jeśli
pomnożymy jakiś wektor Phi przez jakiś skalar alfa, a następnie weźmiemy
iloczyn tensorowy z Psi,
wynik jest taki sam, jak gdybyśmy najpierw wzięli iloczyn tensorowy Phi i Psi, a następnie pomnożyli wynik przez alfa.
Mamy też liniowość
w drugim argumencie, co jest takie samo, z tym że role tych dwóch argumentów są zamienione.
Ta własność dwuliniowości
jest dość prosta do zweryfikowania z definicji, ale dobrze ją zapisać w ten sposób, bo często będziemy
korzystać z tych wzorów.
Zauważ nawiasem mówiąc, że skalary swobodnie przechodzą przez iloczyny tensorowe w sensie wyrażonym przez te
równości, które widzisz tutaj.
To znaczy, nie ma różnicy
między mnożeniem pierwszego argumentu przez
skalar alfa, w tym przypadku mnożeniem drugiego
argumentu przez ten skalar,
a mnożeniem całości
przez ten skalar.
Te równości wynikają z
tych dwóch równań tutaj, i ponieważ nie ma
różnicy między tymi wektorami, możemy po prostu zapisać
wyrażenie jak widać tutaj,
bez nawiasów, bo
nie są one potrzebne.
Nie dodają klarowności
ani nie usuwają niejednoznaczności, więc po prostu je pomijamy i
uzyskujemy czystsze wyrażenie.
Wszystko to uogólnia się
na trzy lub więcej układów.
Możemy zdefiniować iloczyn tensorowy
trzech lub więcej wektorów, uogólniając wzór
na iloczyn tensorowy dwóch wektorów w naturalny sposób,
co widzisz wyrażone tutaj. Każdy wpis iloczynu tensorowego jest dany przez iloczyn
odpowiadających wpisów
wektorów, z których bierzemy
iloczyn tensorowy.
Równoważnym sposobem
zdefiniowania iloczynu tensorowego trzech lub więcej wektorów
jest zrobienie tego rekurencyjnie, ostatecznie odwołując się do definicji
iloczynu tensorowego dwóch wektorów. Tak więc, jeśli n jest przynajmniej trzy, możemy myśleć o
iloczynie tensorowym n wektorów
Phi1 przez Phi n jako o iloczynie tensorowym między wektorem, który uzyskujemy biorąc iloczyn tensorowy pierwszych n minus jeden z
nich, z ostatnim wektorem,
a jeśli chcesz wiedzieć,
jaki jest iloczyn tensorowy pierwszych n minus jeden wektorów, albo stosujesz wzór
ponownie w przypadku, gdy n minus jeden
jest przynajmniej trzy, albo używasz definicji
sprzed chwili, jeśli n minus jeden jest równe dwa.
Dwa sposoby myślenia
o iloczynach tensorowych trzech lub więcej wektorów są równoważne.
Tym razem, gdy mamy
trzy lub więcej wektorów, z których bierzemy iloczyn tensorowy, nie używamy terminu dwuliniowy,
używamy zamiast tego terminu wieloliniowy,
ale idea jest ta sama.
Iloczyn tensorowy jest liniowy
w każdej z pozycji, pod warunkiem, że wektory na
wszystkich pozostałych pozycjach
są ustalone. Przechodząc do pomiarów
wielu układów w stanach probabilistycznych,
natychmiast uzyskujemy specyfikację, jak działają pomiary
dla wielu układów, po prostu myśląc o nich
łącznie jako o pojedynczych układach,
pod warunkiem, że wszystkie
układy są mierzone.
Jako prosty przykład, załóżmy, że mamy dwa
bity X i Y i łącznie są one w tym stanie probabilistycznym
tutaj,
który widzieliśmy wcześniej. Naturalnie, jeśli zmierzymy
oba te bity, otrzymamy wynik 00,
co oznacza zero z pierwszego pomiaru i zero z drugiego pomiaru, z prawdopodobieństwem jedna druga, i otrzymamy wynik 1,1
WEBVTT
z prawdopodobieństwem jedna druga też. To jest dość oczywiste.
W istocie, mierzenie wszystkich układów jest równoważne mierzeniu
całego złożonego układu.
Jeśli jednak nie mierzymy wszystkich
układów, ale zamiast tego mierzymy
tylko niektóre z nich, sytuacja nie jest
od razu tak oczywista.
Ograniczając ponownie uwagę do przypadku tylko dwóch
układów, żeby zobaczyć istotę tego, co się dzieje, w możliwie
prostym ujęciu.
Możemy zadać następujące pytanie: przypuśćmy, że mamy dwa układy X i Y, które są razem jako para
w jakimś konkretnym stanie probabilistycznym.
Co się stanie, jeśli zmierzymy
tylko X i nic nie robimy z Y?
Cóż, możemy odpowiedzieć na to pytanie używając podstawowej teorii prawdopodobieństwa.
Po pierwsze, wiemy, że prawdopodobieństwo, że pomiar
daje konkretny wynik, musi być dane przez ten wzór,
który widzisz tutaj.
Możemy myśleć o prawdopodobieństwach dla każdego ze stanów klasycznych
pary XY tak, jak gdybyśmy zmierzyli oba, i sumujemy wszystkie prawdopodobieństwa,
które są spójne z tym, że X jest w jakimkolwiek stanie klasycznym
a, którym jesteśmy zainteresowani.
Dlatego suma tutaj jest tylko po stanach klasycznych b układu Y.
Jednym ze sposobów myślenia o tym
wzorze jest to, że prawdopodobieństwo zobaczenia konkretnego stanu klasycznego X, jeśli go zmierzymy,
musi być spójne z prawdopodobieństwem zobaczenia tego stanu, gdybyśmy zmierzyli też Y, nawet jeśli tego nie zrobiliśmy,
co jest bardzo naturalne i intuicyjne. Prawdopodobieństwo, że pomiar X daje konkretny wynik, nie może zależeć od tego, czy Y
było też mierzone,
niezależnie od wyniku.
Tak więc to mówi nam,
jakie są prawdopodobieństwa dla różnych możliwych
wyników pomiaru, ale co dzieje się z Y lub z naszą
wiedzą o Y w rezultacie?
Odpowiedź jest taka, że nadal
może istnieć pewna niepewność co do stanu Y w wyniku zmierzenia X
i uzyskania konkretnego wyniku. A ta niepewność jest reprezentowana przez ten wzór tutaj na prawdopodobieństwo warunkowe,
że Y jest w jakimś konkretnym
stanie klasycznym b, pod warunkiem, że X jest w jakimś stanie klasycznym,
cokolwiek to za stan klasyczny a,
który akurat zmierzyliśmy.
Mówiąc precyzyjnie, prawdopodobieństwo, że Y jest
w jakimś stanie klasycznym b, pod warunkiem, że X jest w stanie klasycznym a,
jest równe prawdopodobieństwu,
że X jest w a i Y jest w b, podzielonemu przez prawdopodobieństwo, że X
jest w stanie klasycznym a.
Tak więc, jeśli zmierzymy X, będziemy widzieć
różne stany klasyczne z prawdopodobieństwami wyznaczonymi
przez ten wzór tutaj,
i w zależności od tego, jaki wynik uzyskamy, możemy nadal mieć pewną niepewność co do stanu klasycznego Y, a
ta niepewność jest odzwierciedlona
przez ten wzór tutaj.
Istnieje w rzeczywistości bardzo łatwy
sposób na przeformułowanie tego wszystkiego i wykonywanie obliczeń
dla konkretnych przypadków przy użyciu notacji ket
i wygląda to tak.
Zaczynamy od zapisania
stanu probabilistycznego XY jako wektor w ten sposób, i
to jest zupełnie ogólne.
Wpisy są oznaczane przez Pab i mogą to być dowolne liczby, o ile cały wektor
jest wektorem prawdopodobieństwa.
Możemy wyrazić ket ab jako
iloczyn tensorowy, jak widać tutaj, a następnie możemy użyć
dwuliniowości iloczynu tensorowego,
a konkretnie faktu, że jest liniowy w drugim argumencie, żeby wyrazić ten wektor
jak widać tutaj.
Co robimy, to efektywnie izolujemy wektory bazy standardowej
po lewej stronie i umieszczamy to, czego potrzebujemy,
po prawej stronie,
żeby to umożliwić, bo to ujawni, co się dzieje, gdy mierzymy pierwszy układ X.
Konkretnie, prawdopodobieństwo
uzyskania konkretnego wyniku a jest sumą wszystkich prawdopodobieństw, które pojawiają się
w nawiasach obok ketu a.
A pod warunkiem uzyskania
konkretnego wyniku a, wektor prawdopodobieństwa opisujący wszelką pozostałą niepewność co do Y
jest wektorem, który był
w nawiasach obok a.
Tyle że musimy go znormalizować, żeby był wektorem prawdopodobieństwa, a to oznacza, że
musimy podzielić ten wektor
przez sumę wpisów w tym wektorze, żeby uformować wektor prawdopodobieństwa.
Nawiasem mówiąc, suma jest tutaj brana po wszystkich
c w gamma, a nie po b, tylko żeby użyć innej nazwy zmiennej, żeby nie było żadnych pomyłek
co do zakresu zmiennych,
że tak powiem.
Sumy w liczniku
i mianowniku należy traktować jako oddzielne rzeczy i możemy uniknąć wszelkiej szansy
na pomyłkę co do tego,
używając różnych
zmiennych dla dwóch sum.
Oto szybki przykład
ilustrujący, jak to wszystko działa.
Przypuśćmy, że XY to para bitów w tym stanie probabilistycznym tutaj, żeby zrozumieć, co się dzieje,
gdy mierzymy pierwszy bit
i nic nie robimy z drugim, zapisujemy wektor jak widać tutaj, gdzie ket zero i ket
jeden na pierwszej pozycji
są izolowane dokładnie tak,
jak opisaliśmy chwilę temu.
Pierwszą możliwością jest
to, że wynikiem pomiaru jest zero, a prawdopodobieństwo
tego jest sumą prawdopodobieństw
wewnątrz nawiasów
WEBVTT
które są w iloczynie tensorowym z ketem zero. Więc dostajemy jedną dwunastą plus jedną czwartą, co daje jedną trzecią, i
pod warunkiem wyniku zero.
Stan probabilistyczny Y
staje się tym wektorem znormalizowanym, czyli podzielonym przez prawdopodobieństwo,
które właśnie obliczyliśmy, i tak uzyskujemy
ten wektor tutaj.
Drugą możliwością jest to, że wynikiem pomiaru jest jeden i obliczenia
są wykonywane w podobny sposób, używając drugiego członu w wyrażeniu
zamiast pierwszego. A jeśli chcesz zweryfikować szczegóły, zawsze możesz zatrzymać wideo, żeby dać sobie chwilę na to.
Możesz wykonywać te same
rodzaje obliczeń, żeby dowiedzieć się, co się dzieje, gdy
Y jest mierzony zamiast X.
To ta sama metoda, z uwzględnieniem symetrii między tymi dwoma układami.
Tym razem zapisujemy
wektor prawdopodobieństwa w ten sposób, izolując wektory bazy standardowej po prawej stronie, jak widać tutaj,
ale poza tym działa to
dokładnie w ten sam sposób.
Możesz też użyć tej metody
dla więcej niż dwóch układów.
Może być trochę
nieporządnie przy zapisywaniu wszystkich wymaganych wyrażeń, ale konceptualnie jest to
dokładnie ta sama idea.
Wreszcie, dla części lekcji
dotyczącej informacji klasycznej, przyjrzymy się operacjom
na stanach probabilistycznych
wielu układów. Stosując to samo rozumowanie, które teraz widzieliśmy kilka razy.
Dochodzimy do wniosku, że operacje probabilistyczne na wielu układach są dokładnie
jak operacje probabilistyczne na pojedynczych układach, reprezentowane
przez macierze stochastyczne.
Ale tym razem te macierze
mają wiersze i kolumny odpowiadające iloczynowi kartezjańskiemu zbiorów stanów klasycznych poszczególnych układów.
To znaczy, po prostu
traktujemy złożony układ jak gdyby był pojedynczym układem i odwołujemy się do opisu tego, jak działają operacje probabilistyczne
na pojedynczych układach z
poprzedniej lekcji.
Oto przykład operacji zwanej controlled-NOT
na dwóch bitach X i Y.
Jest to w rzeczywistości operacja deterministyczna i działa ona w ten sposób, że
jeśli X jest równe jeden, to operacja NOT jest wykonywana na Y,
a w przeciwnym razie, jeśli X jest równe
zero, to nic się nie dzieje.
Bit X jest czasami
zwany bitem kontrolnym, bo to on decyduje, czy
operacja NOT jest stosowana do Y,
a Y jest zwany bitem docelowym, bo to ten bit, na który działa operacja NOT.
Można też wyobrazić sobie
zamianę ról X i Y, tak że Y staje się bitem kontrolnym,
a X staje się docelowym, ale to jest inna operacja
od tej, która jest tutaj opisana, bo operacja nie jest
symetryczna między X i Y.
Obie są nazywane
operacjami controlled-NOT, i musimy po prostu określić,
który z bitów jest bitem kontrolnym, a
który jest docelowym.
Ta operacja ma działanie,
które widzisz tutaj na stanach bazy standardowej, i możesz sprawdzić to
działanie względem definicji
operacji. A tutaj jest reprezentacja
macierzowa tej operacji.
Kiedy myślimy o tej operacji, mamy na myśli te
dwa oddzielne bity, które pełnią role, które właśnie opisałem, z
X jako bitem kontrolnym
i Y jako bitem docelowym, ale tak naprawdę nie ma nic
w tym działaniu tutaj ani w tej reprezentacji macierzowej,
co wymagałoby od nas
myślenia o tych dwóch bitach jako o oddzielnych bitach.
Możemy alternatywnie po prostu
myśleć o tej operacji jako o operacji deterministycznej
na układzie mającym cztery stany klasyczne,
które zdecydowaliśmy nazwać
0,0, 0,1, 1,0 i 1,1.
Oto kolejny przykład
operacji probabilistycznej na dwóch bitach, która tym razem nie jest operacją deterministyczną.
Operacja ustawia Y tak, żeby była równa X z prawdopodobieństwem jedna druga, a w przeciwnym razie idzie w drugą stronę i ustawia X tak, żeby była równa Y.
Ta operacja nie ma specjalnej nazwy, jest tylko przykładem.
A oto reprezentacja
macierzowa tej operacji.
Możesz zobaczyć, że może być wyrażona jako średnia dwóch macierzy, jednej reprezentującej operację deterministyczną,
gdzie Y jest ustawiane na wartość
przechowywaną w X, i drugiej, która ustawia
X tak, żeby była równa Y.
Tutaj widzimy więc, że możemy brać średnie macierzy stochastycznych, żeby uzyskiwać nowe, tak samo jak w poprzedniej lekcji.
Teraz rozważmy
następujące pytanie. Załóżmy, że mamy dwie
operacje probabilistyczne, każda na własnym układzie,
opisane jak zwykle przez macierze
stochastyczne, i mówiąc precyzyjnie, załóżmy, że M jest
operacją probabilistyczną
na układzie X, a N jest
operacją probabilistyczną na układzie Y.
Pytanie brzmi: jeśli
jednocześnie wykonamy M na X i N na Y, jak opisujemy
efekt, który to ma
na złożony układ XY?
Myśląc o tym intuicyjnie przez chwilę, jeśli jednocześnie
wykonujemy dwie operacje na ich własnych układach,
to w rzeczywistości
wykonujemy operację na złożonym układzie, więc powinna być opisana
przez jakąś macierz stochastyczną.
Krótka odpowiedź na to
pytanie jest taka, że macierz jest uzyskiwana przez wzięcie iloczynu tensorowego, nie między wektorami, jak
omawialiśmy wcześniej,
WEBVTT
ale między macierzami, w tym
przypadku macierzami M i N.
Poświęćmy więc kilka chwil
na omówienie iloczynów tensorowych macierzy, a potem wrócimy
do tego pytania.
Oto definicja
iloczynu tensorowego między macierzami i
jest ona bardzo analogiczna do iloczynu tensorowego między wektorami.
Jeśli przyjmiemy, że dwie
macierze, z którymi pracujemy, są zapisane w postaciach, które widzisz tutaj, tak że wpisy M są
oznaczane alfa ab, gdzie a i b
obiegają pewien zbiór stanów klasycznych sigma, a wpisy N są
oznaczane przez beta cd, gdzie c i d
obiegają pewien zbiór stanów klasycznych gamma.
Wtedy iloczyn M i N jest macierzą, którą widzisz tutaj.
To, co mamy, jest podobne
do iloczynu tensorowego między wektorami.
Wiersze i kolumny M tensor N odpowiadają parom stanów klasycznych, które są tu zapisane jako ciągi znaków,
a wpisy są iloczynami odpowiadających wpisów M i N.
Oto inny sposób zapisania tego w kategoriach indywidualnych
wpisów tych macierzy.
Wpis ac bd w M tensor N jest iloczynem wpisu ab
w M i wpisu cd w N.
Istnieje inny sposób
opisania M tensor N, a mianowicie, że jest to
jedyna macierz, która przekształca dowolny wektor postaci Phi tensor Psi
w iloczyn tensorowy M zastosowanego do Phi z N zastosowanym do Psi, i musi to być prawdą dla każdego wyboru
tych wektorów Phi i Psi.
Jednym ze sposobów myślenia o tym
jest to, że iloczyn tensorowy macierzy doskonale współgra z iloczynem tensorowym między wektorami.
Jest to równanie, na którego
prawdziwość naturalnie byś liczył, i rzeczywiście jest ono prawdziwe.
W kategoriach macierzy
zapisanych explicite, możemy zdefiniować iloczyn
tensorowy jak widać tutaj.
Jest wiele kropek w tym równaniu i mają one
zilustrować wzorzec, który jest taki sam
jak wzorzec dla wektorów, z tym że teraz mamy wiersze i kolumny
zamiast tylko wektorów kolumnowych.
Jeśli nie jest to jasne, następujący przykład może pomóc.
Tutaj mówimy o
iloczynie tensorowym dwóch macierzy dwa na dwa.
Najpierw zapisujemy cztery
kopie drugiej macierzy, po jednej dla każdego wpisu pierwszej macierzy.
Mnożymy każdą z tych
kopii drugiej macierzy przez odpowiadający
wpis pierwszej macierzy,
a następnie zbieramy to wszystko w
jedną macierz cztery na cztery, jak widać tutaj.
Możemy też zdefiniować
iloczyn tensorowy trzech lub więcej macierzy w analogiczny sposób, a chyba najprostszym
sposobem na wyrażenie tego
jest tak, jak widać tutaj,
gdzie mamy wzór na każdy wpis iloczynu tensorowego, który jest po prostu iloczynem
odpowiadających wpisów.
Możesz też definiować iloczyn tensorowy trzech lub więcej macierzy rekurencyjnie w kategoriach iloczynu
tensorowego tylko dwóch macierzy, tak samo jak mieliśmy dla wektorów.
I ostatnia uwaga jest
taka, że iloczyn tensorowy macierzy jest multiplikatywny, co oznacza, że
iloczyn iloczynów tensorowych
jest równy iloczynowi tensorowemu
iloczynów.
Możesz myśleć o tym
jako o uogólnieniu wzoru sprzed chwili na działanie iloczynu
tensorowego macierzy
na iloczyn tensorowy wektorów. I znowu, to jest coś, w prawdziwość czego
naturalnie byś liczył, i możemy się cieszyć, że tak jest,
i będziemy z tego faktu
korzystać, gdy zajdzie taka potrzeba.
A teraz możemy wrócić do
pytania sprzed chwili, które pyta, jak opisujemy
efekt wykonania operacji M na układzie X
i operacji N na układzie Y razem jako operacji
na złożonym układzie XY.
A odpowiedź na to
pytanie jest taka, że działanie jest opisane przez
iloczyn tensorowy M i N.
Iloczyny tensorowe reprezentują niezależność, tym razem między operacjami, w odróżnieniu od tego, co widzieliśmy
wcześniej dla wektorów prawdopodobieństwa.
Oto szybki przykład. Przypuśćmy, że wykonujemy
operację probabilistyczną opisaną przez tę macierz na bicie X.
To jest operacja,
którą widzieliśmy w lekcji pierwszej, i jednocześnie wykonujemy
operację NOT na bicie Y.
Połączona operacja na parze XY jest zatem reprezentowana przez iloczyn tensorowy macierzy odpowiadających tym dwóm operacjom.
Oto ta na X i
oto operacja NOT na Y, i otrzymujemy tę macierz,
którą widzisz tutaj.
I możesz zobaczyć, że rzeczywiście
jest to macierz stochastyczna, i tak będzie zawsze.
Iloczyn tensorowy dowolnych
dwóch macierzy stochastycznych lub dowolnej liczby macierzy stochastycznych
będzie zawsze stochastyczny.
Bardzo często zdarza się
sytuacja, w której jedna operacja jest
wykonywana na jednym układzie i nic nie jest robione z innym układem.
W tej sytuacji stosujemy dokładnie ten sam przepis, rozumiejąc, że nierobienie niczego jest reprezentowane przez macierz jednostkową.
Na przykład, jeśli mamy dwa bity X i
Y i resetujemy bit X do stanu zero, co jest tym samym,
co wykonanie stałej
funkcji zerowej na X i nic nie robimy z Y, to wynikowa operacja na parze XY
WEBVTT
jest reprezentowana przez ten
iloczyn tensorowy tutaj.
Wszystko to uogólnia się
na dowolną liczbę układów i zobaczymy dodatkowe przykłady, gdy przejdziemy do ujęcia kwantowego, które działa dokładnie w ten sam sposób,
z tym że mamy macierze unitarne zamiast macierzy stochastycznych, i to wystarczy
o informacji klasycznej na teraz.
Teraz skierujemy uwagę
na informację kwantową i to, jak działa dla wielu układów.
Wzorzec jest taki sam, jak
był dla informacji klasycznej.
Możemy traktować wiele układów kwantowych jako pojedyncze złożone układy i stosować to, co wiemy
z poprzedniej lekcji.
Znowu, iloczyny tensorowe
będą odgrywać kluczową rolę i ogólnie rzecz biorąc, uzyskujemy opis tego, jak działa informacja kwantowa
dla wielu układów.
Który jest bardzo analogiczny
i matematycznie podobny do tego, co właśnie widzieliśmy dla
informacji klasycznej.
Zaczniemy od stanów kwantowych.
Stany kwantowe wielu układów są reprezentowane przez wektory kolumnowe o współczynnikach zespolonych
i normie euklidesowej równej jeden,
tak samo jak stany kwantowe
pojedynczych układów.
Tym razem indeksy
wektorów stanu kwantowego odpowiadają iloczynowi kartezjańskiemu zbiorów stanów klasycznych
poszczególnych układów,
ponieważ znowu, to jest
zbiór stanów klasycznych złożonego układu.
Na przykład, jeśli X i Y to qubity, to zbiorem stanów klasycznych
pary XY razem jest iloczyn kartezjański alfabetu binarnego z sobą samym,
który możemy traktować jako
zbiór wszystkich binarnych ciągów znaków długości dwa.
Więc te wektory, które widzisz tutaj, są wszystkie przykładami wektorów
stanu kwantowego XY.
Jeśli chcemy, możemy alternatywnie zapisywać
te wektory w ten sposób, gdzie mamy oddzielny
ket dla każdego qubitu,
gdzie iloczyn tensorowy
między nimi jest domyślny.
Lub możemy też zapisać
symbol iloczynu tensorowego explicite w ten sposób, jeśli wolisz.
I kolejną opcją jest
indeksowanie ketów nazwami układów,
które reprezentują, w ten sposób.
I możesz to robić z
symbolem iloczynu tensorowego lub bez.
To może być czasami bardzo pomocne, żeby nie mieszać pojęć.
To są tylko różne style wyrażania tych samych wektorów i możemy wybrać ten, który chcemy lub wolimy, lub
który ma największy sens
dla danej sytuacji. Gdy rzeczy stają się bardziej
skomplikowane, możemy na przykład zdecydować, że jeden z
tych stylów dodaje klarowności
i możemy swobodnie dokonywać
takiego wyboru.
Iloczyny tensorowe wektorów stanu kwantowego są też wektorami stanu kwantowego.
W przypadku dwóch układów na przykład, jeśli Phi jest wektorem stanu kwantowego
układu X, a Psi jest wektorem stanu kwantowego
układu Y,
to iloczyn tensorowy Phi i Psi jest wektorem stanu kwantowego XY.
Stany takie nazywamy stanami produktowymi i podobnie do tego, co widzieliśmy w probabilistycznym ujęciu klasycznym, reprezentują one niezależność
między układami X i Y.
Tak więc na przykład, jeśli jedna osoba ma laboratorium
w jednej części świata i tworzy układ X, inicjalizując go w stanie kwantowym Phi,
i inna osoba w
innej części świata niezależnie inicjalizuje układ Y w stanie kwantowym Psi,
to jeśli zdecydujemy się myśleć o XY jako tworzących jeden układ, nawet jeśli są dwiema częściami w różnych częściach świata,
to złożony układ XY jest
w stanie Phi tensor Psi.
Wszystko to uogólnia się na
ponad dwa układy w naturalny sposób.
Jeśli mamy stany kwantowe
Psi1 przez PsiN oddzielnych układów X1 przez Xn, to iloczyn tensorowy tych n wektorów
reprezentuje stan kwantowy, który znowu jest zwany stanem produktowym złożonego układu X1 przez Xn.
Oto przykład stanu
kwantowego dwóch qubitów.
Choć może to nie być od razu oczywiste, jest to przykład stanu produktowego, bo możemy zapisać
go jako iloczyn tensorowy, jak widać tutaj.
Jest więc przykładem stanu
produktowego, niezależnie od tego, jak jest zapisany — istotne jest to, czy
jest możliwe zapisanie go jako iloczyn tensorowy.
Ten stan kwantowy natomiast, który jest znowu stanem dwóch
qubitów, nie jest stanem produktowym.
Jest podobny duchem do
przykładu, który widzieliśmy w probabilistycznym ujęciu dwóch doskonale skorelowanych losowych bitów,
i ten sam argument ujawnia, że nie może być zapisany
jako iloczyn tensorowy.
Przesuńmy to więc tutaj i przyjrzyjmy się argumentowi nieco bardziej szczegółowo.
Wyobraźmy sobie, że
moglibyśmy zapisać ten stan jako iloczyn tensorowy
dwóch wektorów Phi i Psi.
Wpis odpowiadający
stanowi klasycznemu 0,1 jest zerem dla tego wektora, co możemy zobaczyć po prostu na niego patrząc.
Implikowałoby to jednak, gdyby wektor był iloczynem tensorowym dwóch wektorów, że wpis zerowy Phi
razy wpis jedynkowy Psi
byłby równy zero, ale to oznacza, że albo
wpis zerowy Phi, albo wpis jedynkowy Psi jest równy zero,
lub oba mogą być równe zero, ale to jest sprzeczne z faktem,
że te dwa iloczyny tutaj muszą być oba niezerowe.
WEBVTT
Są równe jeden
przez pierwiastek z dwóch. Argument jest w rzeczywistości niemal
identyczny z tym, który mieliśmy w ujęciu probabilistycznym.
Nie ma tu nic wyjątkowo
kwantowego.
W każdym razie, to co stwierdzamy, to że oryginalny stan nie jest stanem produktowym.
Zauważ, że nie jest ważne,
że te dwie liczby tutaj to jeden przez pierwiastek z dwóch.
Liczy się tylko to, że
obie wartości są niezerowe.
Ten konkretny stan kwantowy
jest bardzo interesujący. Jest przykładem stanu
splątanego dwóch qubitów.
Więcej o splątaniu
powiemy później w serii.
Splątanie może być skomplikowane, szczególnie gdy mówi o stanach kwantowych w ogólnym sformułowaniu
informacji kwantowej,
ale tutaj, w uproszczonym opisie informacji kwantowej, splątanie jest równoważne brakowi niezależności.
Tak więc dla wektora stanu kwantowego,
jeśli nie jest stanem produktowym, jest stanem splątanym,
i ten konkretny stan
jest powszechnie uważany za
archetypowy przykład splątanego stanu kwantowego.
I w rzeczywistości, czasami
myślimy o tym stanie jako o reprezentującym jedną jednostkę splątania, szczególnie gdy traktujemy splątanie
jako zasób, który można
wykorzystywać do interesujących rzeczy.
Stan kwantowy, o którym
właśnie mówiliśmy, jest jednym z czterech tak zwanych stanów Bella, które możesz tu zobaczyć
wraz z nazwami,
które są powszechnie używane dla tych stanów: Phi plus, Phi minus,
Psi plus i Psi minus.
Wszystkie są splątane
i tworzą bazę dla przestrzeni wszystkich
wektorów reprezentujących stany dwóch qubitów.
Tak więc te cztery wektory razem
są zwane bazą Bella.
Jest to bardzo często spotykany zbiór stanów kwantowych, nazwany
na cześć Johna Bella, który był fizykiem, który wniósł
bardzo ważny wkład
w badania splątania w latach 60.
Oto kilka dobrze znanych przykładów stanów kwantowych trzech qubitów.
Pierwszy z nich nazywa się stanem GHZ.
Jest trochę jak stan Phi
plus, który właśnie widzieliśmy, ale dla trzech qubitów zamiast dwóch.
A drugi przykład nazywa się stanem W i wygląda jak widać tutaj, więc jest jednorodny po
trzech binarnych ciągach znaków
długości trzy, które mają
dokładnie jeden bit ustawiony na jeden.
Żaden z tych stanów nie jest stanem produktowym i oba mają interesujące właściwości i pojawiają się dość często jako przykłady, więc warto je znać
i będziemy je znowu widzieć.
Następnie porozmawiamy o
pomiarach układów w stanach kwantowych.
Stosując to samo rozumowanie,
które stosowaliśmy w tej lekcji, czyli myślenie o wielu układach
jak o pojedynczych układach, natychmiast dochodzimy do opisu tego, jak działają pomiary
wielu układów kwantowych,
pod warunkiem, że wszystkie
układy są mierzone.
To znaczy, jeśli mamy
pewien wektor stanu kwantowego Psi reprezentujący stan kwantowy n-krotki układów
X1 przez Xn i mierzymy
cały złożony układ, co jest równoważne zmierzeniu
każdego z poszczególnych układów, to każda możliwa n-krotka
stanów klasycznych będzie wynikiem pomiaru
z prawdopodobieństwem równym
kwadratowi wartości bezwzględnej wpisu Psi, który
odpowiada tej n-krotce.
Na przykład, jeśli mamy
parę układów XY w tym stanie kwantowym tutaj, to jeśli zmierzymy oba układy,
to otrzymamy wynik zero kier, co oznacza zero z pomiaru X i kier z pomiaru Y,
z prawdopodobieństwem dziewięć dwudziestych piątych, i otrzymamy wynik jeden
pik z prawdopodobieństwem 16/25.
To jest naprawdę dość proste. Zasadniczo ignorujemy fakt, że są to dwa oddzielne układy i traktujemy je jak gdyby
były jednym układem,
ale rodzi to
następujące naturalne pytanie, które już rozważaliśmy
w ujęciu klasycznym.
Przypuśćmy, że mamy dwa układy X i Y, które łącznie
są w jakimś stanie kwantowym i nie mierzymy obu, ale
mierzymy tylko jeden układ.
Powiedzmy, że mierzymy układ X i nic nie robimy z Y.
Oczywiście, możemy też zapytać, co się dzieje, gdy mierzymy Y, a nie
X, i bardziej ogólnie, co się dzieje, gdy mamy
trzy lub więcej układów
i mierzymy pewien właściwy podzbiór z nich. Ale gdy będziemy mieć odpowiedź na to pytanie, będziemy mieć odpowiedzi
na tamte pytania też.
Wiemy, że ogólnie
wektor stanu kwantowego pary XY przyjmuje
postać, którą widzisz tutaj, zakładając jak zwykle, że sigma i gamma
są zbiorami stanów klasycznych
odpowiednio X i Y.
Wpisy tego wektora są
oznaczane przez alfa ab, gdzie a i b obiegają wszystkie możliwe wybory,
i mogą być dowolnymi liczbami zespolonymi, które sprawiają, że ten wektor
jest wektorem jednostkowym.
Wiemy już, że jeśli
oba układy są mierzone, to uzyskujemy prawdopodobieństwa dla różnych możliwych wyników
WEBVTT
biorąc kwadrat wartości bezwzględnej odpowiadającego wpisu.
Tak więc, jeśli mierzony jest tylko X, to prawdopodobieństwo uzyskania konkretnego wyniku a jest dane przez to wyrażenie,
po prostu sumujemy po wszystkich
możliwych wynikach b, które mogłyby być uzyskane,
gdyby Y też było mierzone, nawet jeśli tak nie było.
Idea jest ta sama, co w
ujęciu probabilistycznym.
Prawdopodobieństwo uzyskania
konkretnego wyniku podczas mierzenia X nie może
zależeć od tego, czy Y też było mierzone.
Tak więc to mówi nam,
jakie są prawdopodobieństwa dla różnych możliwych wyników.
Ponadto, nastąpi jakaś
zmiana stanu Y w wyniku wykonania tego pomiaru na X i uzyskania konkretnego wyniku.
Przyjrzyjmy się więc, jak to działa.
Podobnie do tego, co zrobiliśmy w
ujęciu probabilistycznym, możemy wyrazić
wektor stanu kwantowego Psi jak widać tutaj,
gdzie Phi a jest tym wektorem dla każdego wyboru stanu klasycznego a układu X,
używamy dwuliniowości
iloczynu tensorowego jak wcześniej.
Tylko tym razem zdecydowaliśmy się nazwać
te różne wektory Phi a, tylko dla wygody.
Już zaobserwowaliśmy, że prawdopodobieństwo, że pomiar daje
każdy możliwy wynik a jest jak widać tutaj,
ale teraz możemy zobaczyć, że to prawdopodobieństwo jest równe kwadratowi normy euklidesowej wektora Phi a,
i teraz w wyniku pomiaru X dającego konkretny wynik a, mamy, że stan kwantowy
złożonego układu XY
staje się tym stanem,
który widzisz tutaj.
Tak samo jak mieliśmy dla pojedynczych układów, stan zasadniczo kolapsuje, ale nie kolapsuje
całkowicie w ogólności,
kolapsuje tylko tak bardzo, jak trzeba, żeby być spójnym
z pomiarem X dającym wynik a.
Stan kwantowy Y staje się Phi a znormalizowanym, co oznacza, że
dzielimy przez jego normę euklidesową,
żeby stał się wektorem jednostkowym. To jest analogiczne do tego, co się stało w
ujęciu probabilistycznym, gdzie zamiast dzielenia
przez normę euklidesową,
dzieliliśmy przez sumę
wpisów Phi a, żeby uzyskać wektor prawdopodobieństwa.
Ale tutaj, ponieważ
mówimy o stanach kwantowych, dzielimy przez normę euklidesową
żeby uzyskać wektor stanu kwantowego.
Przyjrzyjmy się kilku przykładom, żeby zobaczyć, jak to działa
dla konkretnego stanu.
Oto stan, który rozważymy. Zakładamy, że X i Y to qubity i są w tym konkretnym stanie Psi.
I załóżmy, że mierzony jest X.
Zaczynamy od zapisania stanu
Psi jak widać tutaj, efektywnie izolując
czynniki bazy standardowej X
i biorąc ich iloczyn tensorowy z tym, czego potrzebujemy, żeby uzyskać oryginalny stan.
Tak samo jak w ogólnym
opisie sprzed chwili.
Prawdopodobieństwo uzyskania wyniku zero to kwadrat normy euklidesowej
tego wektora tutaj.
Tego, z którym ket zero jest w iloczynie tensorowym w naszym wyrażeniu wektora Psi.
I tak prawdopodobieństwo wynosi trzy czwarte i pod warunkiem
uzyskania wyniku zero.
Stan kwantowy
pary XY staje się tym, gdzie normalizujemy
wektor w iloczynie tensorowym z ketem zero,
co jest równoważne
dzieleniu przez pierwiastek z prawdopodobieństwa, które
właśnie obliczyliśmy.
Możemy potem uprościć
i to jest to, co uzyskujemy.
Prawdopodobieństwo uzyskania
wyniku pomiaru jeden jest obliczane w podobny sposób.
Bierzemy kwadrat normy euklidesowej
tego wektora tutaj. Tego, który jest w iloczynie tensorowym z ketem
jeden w naszym wyrażeniu Psi,
i wynikowe
prawdopodobieństwo wynosi jedna czwarta, co musi tak być oczywiście, bo nasze prawdopodobieństwa
muszą sumować się do jeden.
W tym przypadku, stan kwantowy XY staje się tym, gdzie znowu normalizujemy przez dzielenie przez normę euklidesową,
żeby uzyskać ten wektor
stanu kwantowego w wyniku.
Ta sama metoda jest używana
symetrycznie, jeśli Y jest mierzony zamiast X.
Oto oryginalny wektor stanu kwantowego, i tym razem, bo Y
jest mierzony zamiast X,
wyrażamy wektor Psi
jak widać tutaj, gdzie tym razem izolujemy wektory
bazy standardowej Y
zamiast X, biorąc
iloczyn tensorowy z tym, czego potrzebujemy, żeby uzyskać wyrażenie Psi.
Wykonując obliczenia, które możesz sprawdzić, zatrzymując
wideo, jeśli chcesz.
Widzimy, że prawdopodobieństwo
uzyskania wyniku zero wynosi tym razem Phi osiem, i oto wektor stanu kwantowego
będący wynikiem pod warunkiem
uzyskania tego wyniku.
A prawdopodobieństwo uzyskania
wyniku jeden wynosi trzy ósme, w którym to przypadku to jest
nasz wektor stanu kwantowego.
Możesz użyć dokładnie tej samej metody w przypadku, gdy masz więcej niż dwa układy i mierzony jest dowolny właściwy podzbiór z nich.
WEBVTT
I jest przykład
w treściach podręcznikowych do tej lekcji, który możesz sprawdzić, jeśli jesteś zainteresowany.
Krótko mówiąc, zawsze możemy podzielić układy na dwie oddzielne kolekcje: te, które są mierzone,
i te, które nie są.
A gdy to zrobimy, korzystamy z metody
którą właśnie opisałem, i tak działają pomiary dla wielu układów kwantowych.
A teraz wreszcie, przechodzi na operacje unitarne
na wielu układach.
Używając tej samej podstawowej idei, że wiele układów może być traktowanych jako pojedyncze złożone układy.
Dochodzimy do wniosku, który widzisz
napisany tutaj na ekranie: operacje kwantowe na złożonych układach są reprezentowane przez macierze unitarne,
tak samo jak dla pojedynczych układów, a konkretnie, wiersze i kolumny tych macierzy unitarnych odpowiadają iloczynowi kartezjańskiemu
zbiorów stanów klasycznych jakiejkolwiek kolekcji
układów, o której mówimy.
Na przykład, jeśli mamy układ X,
którego stany klasyczne to jeden, dwa i trzy, i Y jest qubitem,
to macierz, którą widzisz tutaj, jest przykładem macierzy unitarnej, która reprezentuje
operację na parze XY.
Szczegóły dotyczące tego, jak porządkujemy iloczyny kartezjańskie, o których mówiliśmy wcześniej, tak naprawdę nie mają znaczenia
dla tego przykładu, to jest po prostu macierz sześć na sześć,
która akurat jest unitarna.
Nie ma w niej nic wyjątkowego, choć jest zbudowana z
kilku ważnych macierzy.
Chodzi o to, że możesz
wybrać dowolną macierz unitarną sześć na sześć i reprezentowałaby
ona operację unitarną na XY.
Jeśli stosujemy zbiór
operacji unitarnych, każda niezależnie na własnym układzie, to działanie ich wszystkich razem
na złożonym układzie jest
dane przez iloczyn tensorowy.
I tutaj na ekranie możesz zobaczyć bardziej precyzyjne
sformułowanie tego faktu.
Jeśli nasze operacje unitarne są opisane przez macierze unitarne U1 przez Un, po jednej dla każdego z naszych układów,
to łączne działanie
na złożonym układzie jest dane przez iloczyn
tensorowy U1 przez Un.
Ponownie, podobnie do tego, co mieliśmy w ujęciu probabilistycznym, ważnym przykładem jest to, że stosujemy jakąś operację unitarną
U do układu X i nic
nie robimy z jakimś innym układem Y.
Operacja na XY, którą uzyskujemy, to U w iloczynie tensorowym z macierzą jednostkową.
Macierz jednostkowa
opisuje nierobienie niczego z Y.
Czasami pomocne jest wyraźne napisanie, że ta macierz jednostkowa
odpowiada układowi Y, tylko żeby wzory były bardziej czytelne.
I jedną z opcji jest
nadanie macierzy jednostkowej indeksu dolnego w ten sposób, wskazującego układ, na który działa.
Gdy jest to wystarczająco czytelne, zazwyczaj nie zawracamy sobie głowy indeksem dolnym, ale gdy rzeczy stają się bardziej skomplikowane, może być to bardzo pomocne.
Możemy też rozważać
symetryczny przypadek, gdzie jakaś operacja unitarna
V jest stosowana do Y i nic nie jest robione z X,
i tym razem wynikowa
operacja unitarna na XY jest reprezentowana przez ten
iloczyn tensorowy tutaj.
I znowu, możemy umieścić indeks dolny na
macierzy jednostkowej, jeśli to pomaga.
Oto kilka konkretnych przykładów.
Jeśli X i Y to qubity i
wykonujemy operację Hadamard na X i nic nie robimy z Y, uzyskujemy macierz, którą widzisz tutaj.
Jeśli z drugiej strony, wykonujemy operację Hadamard na Y i nic nie robimy z X, kolejność iloczynu tensorowego jest odwrócona.
I tak uzyskujemy macierz
którą widzisz tutaj.
Nie każda operacja unitarna
na złożonym układzie może być wyrażona jako iloczyn tensorowy.
Jeśli mamy iloczyn tensorowy,
to mamy niezależność.
I są pewne dość
fundamentalne przykłady operacji, które z pewnością
nie działają niezależnie na wielu układach.
Na przykład, jeśli X i Y mają
ten sam zbiór stanów klasycznych, którym może być dowolny
zbiór stanów klasycznych sigma,
to możemy myśleć o
operacji swap na parze XY.
Ta operacja nie zmienia kolejności dwóch układów, nadal mamy X po
lewej i Y po prawej, ale raczej reprezentuje
zamianę zawartości
tych dwóch układów. Tutaj możesz zobaczyć to wyrażone
w postaci równania, gdzie mamy iloczyn
tensorowy dwóch stanów kwantowych.
Innym sposobem zapisania tego jest
macierz, jak widzimy tutaj.
Sposób, w jaki możesz myśleć
o tym opisie, to że mówi ci, co się dzieje dla wektorów bazy standardowej.
A gdy wiemy, co się dzieje
dla wektorów bazy standardowej, wiemy, co się dzieje dla
dowolnych stanów kwantowych przez liniowość,
co w rzeczywistości jest też prawdą dla
tego wyrażenia tutaj.
Tak więc ta konkretna operacja tutaj jest zarówno operacją deterministyczną, jak i operacją unitarną.
Jeśli X i Y to qubity na przykład, uzyskujemy tę reprezentację macierzową tutaj.
Oto interesujące powiązanie
między operacją swap i czterema stanami Bella, które są pokazane tutaj dla wygody.
Operacja swap pozostawia
pierwsze trzy z nich bez zmian, ale dodaje znak minus
przed stanem Psi minus,
więc jest w tym
coś wyjątkowego.
Możesz sprawdzić te równania bezpośrednio, przyglądając się tym wektorom i zastanawiając się, co dzieje się
ze standardowymi stanami bazowymi.
Zamiana dwóch klasycznych stanów dla pierwszych trzech stanów Bella
nic nie zmienia – otrzymujemy ten sam stan, od którego zaczęliśmy.
W czwartym przypadku jednak znak minus efektywnie
przechodzi z jednego składnika do drugiego, gdy wykonujemy zamianę klasycznych stanów,
a to jest równoważne pomnożeniu wektora przez minus jeden.
Tak więc wykonanie operacji zamiany niejako „wyrzuca" znak minus
z tego czwartego stanu Bella.
Powiemy jeszcze więcej o
tych równaniach później, ale teraz przejdźmy do
innego rodzaju operacji, czyli operacji sterowanej.
Przyjmiemy, że X jest qubit, a Y jest dowolnym układem.
Jeśli U jest operacją unitarną na Y, to sterowana operacja U na XY jest operacją
wyrażoną tutaj.
Najpierw używając notacji bezpośredniej, a następnie używając tak zwanej
macierzy blokowej – wyobraź sobie wypełnienie
tej większej macierzy
mniejszymi, gdzie te zera naprawdę reprezentują macierze
wypełnione zerami.
Każdy z tych czterech bloków reprezentuje macierz o liczbie
wierszy i kolumn zgodnej z liczbą
klasycznych stanów Y.
Idea operacji sterowanej, którą już napotkaliśmy
w ujęciu klasycznym, gdy omawialiśmy
operację sterowanego NOT,
polega na tym, że jeśli X jest ustawiony na zero,
to nic nie dzieje się z Y.
Ale jeśli X jest ustawiony na jeden,
to U jest stosowane do Y.
Tak więc X nazywany jest kontrolnym qubit, a Y nazywany jest układem docelowym, który w ogólności
nie musi być qubit.
Jako konkretny przykład,
który właśnie wspomniałem, mamy operację sterowanego NOT.
Jeśli pierwszy qubit jest ustawiony
na zero, nic się nie dzieje. A jeśli pierwszy qubit jest ustawiony na jeden, to operacja NOT, lub równoważnie,
operacja sigma X jest
stosowana do drugiego qubit.
A oto jej reprezentacja macierzowa.
Mówimy tu o dwóch qubit, więc równie dobrze możemy
zdecydować, że drugi qubit jest sterującym, a
pierwszy jest docelowym.
Aby opisać tę operację, po prostu zamieniamy kolejność
w iloczynie tensorowym, a wynikiem jest macierz,
którą widzisz tutaj.
Jeśli zamiast operacji sterowanego NOT rozważymy sterowane sigma
Z, czyli operację sterowanego Z,
otrzymamy tę reprezentację macierzową tutaj. W tym przypadku nie ma znaczenia,
który jest sterującym, a który docelowym.
Wynik jest taki sam w obu przypadkach.
Możemy pójść dalej i rozważyć sterowaną operację zamiany.
Tutaj mówimy
o zamianie dwóch qubit, więc kończymy z trzema qubit, gdy uwzględnimy sterujący qubit.
Każda reprezentacja macierzowa
wygląda tak.
To dość wyjątkowa operacja i jest znana jako operacja Fredkina, lub częściej gate Fredkina.
Gdy myślimy o niej
jako o gate w circuit, omówimy circuit w następnej lekcji.
Ostatnim przykładem jest sterowana
operacja sterowanego NOT, która znowu jest
operacją na trzech qubit.
A oto jej reprezentacja macierzowa. Ta operacja jest znacznie lepiej
znana jako operacja Toffliego lub gate Toffoliego.
Omówimy ją dalej
i zobaczymy, dlaczego zarówno ona, jak i operacja gate Fredkina są bardzo ważnymi
operacjami w późniejszej lekcji.
I to jest koniec drugiej lekcji. W tej lekcji omówiliśmy, jak działa informacja kwantowa dla wielu układów.
Mam nadzieję, że dołączysz do mnie
na trzecią lekcję wkrótce, która dotyczy circuit kwantowych,
protokołów i gier.
Do zobaczenia!